let's get into this album Henny okay
because like three weeks at number one
on the billboard hot 100.
but like okay what's unreal to me is the
fact that this is your first number one
in the U.S yes Matt I can't think of
life I don't even know how many songs
that I thought were number one it was
hard to get a number one here it really
is like it's crazy hello
no it's been beautiful amazing and
Unholy is nominated for a Grammy
congratulations fabulous yes right yeah
I'm excited for the outfits that I'm
gonna wear yeah
um it's gonna be great
um yeah it's been great I'm I mean look
these what means the most is just the
music it's the it's the me and Kim
created something and it's a little baby
and we just never thought people would
react to like this and it's so nice to
to to know that the world is
dropping to yourself
I have been doing some moves that's good
that's what we did it's gorgeous I love
it
started on the video it's fine it's so
fun it's so good I did also spot a
little Violet shot
yes yes yes incredible so I heard that
you were on the way to the gym when you
found out about
I did like okay this is dedication yeah
it's a rare occurrence these days
actually I need I meant to be on tour I
need to up my gem game and get moving a
bit more okay I do like I need to know
what do you like at the gym are you
refocused are we checking out all the
trade that's there are we talking all
the machines no we are moaning we're
really boning uh hating every second
doing the bare minimum okay um
drinking some water looking in the
mirror dancing
yeah exactly exactly I love it I mean
yeah that you know we have our good
day's favorite yeah exactly exactly as
long as we're there yeah exactly get
your body there your mind will follow
that's okay I love that so on this album
you worked with so many incredible
artists and let's talk about our friend
Ed yes okay like what was it like
working with Ed and like how did this
come about it was beautiful we've been
friends for a long time and we've always
wanted to work on a piece of music
together and this happened just so
naturally and I love the record so much
and he is such a dear special person to
me and um to share a song like this and
it's the end of the album and it's just
everything Feels So Perfect about it I
love it that's precious yeah and I know
that you also had another collaboration
with our Canadian Queen Jesse Reyes oh
God two tracks right two tracks and
she's also wrote and appears on another
one too okay she's
incredible edible and really is
harnessed like she she created a safe
space for me like there's a lot of the
rooms that I've written songs in I've
always been with guys and being in the
room with her she she lets me talk about
things
um and takes me to places lyrically and
and that I and melodically that that I
haven't felt I've had permission to go
and um it's really beautiful she she
championed me and um I hope that I do
the same for her because she's
Sensational so Shania Twain's Man I Feel
Like a Woman is the number one karaoke
song of all time yeah what's your go-to
karaoke song oh my gosh I hate karaoke
I know I hate it because I feel like
people that can sing ruin karaoke I just
feel like if you're gonna kill karaoke
you've got to be bad okay because I was
like hoping for like a Sam
oh my God
never voice
never and if I did I'd probably just
sing like Abba gimme gimme gimme okay
that's yeah uh
okay all right okay I like that one you
have several tattoos but I understand
there are a few you don't you know
you're not a fan of oh yeah
all right so what's your least favorite
tattoo it has to be this badly done
anchor it's well it's not badly done
it's just starting to bleed out and it's
not great
um so I got one on my neck now which I
prefer very delicate um but yeah it's
probably that okay boring answer right
now I mean no it's like it's cute so I
got the word alone tattooed on my arm
because I'm a drama queen I mean um when
I was like 20 something so it's really
embarrassing so I got like a duck put on
top of it oh I love it it's great yeah
it's like alone with my deck yes exactly
you get it all right so who is the most
famous person in your phone that you
last called or texted and what was it
what was the call what was the text I
don't know I used to have loads of
famous people in my phone but like I
feel like they've all changed their
numbers now because I just Stone it was
years ago okay but probably is Ed yeah
probably yeah it doesn't really have a
phone oh so it's more like
messaging on other things okay
um but yeah
Ed let's go to McDonald's I want the
like party pack let's go yeah yeah I'm
trying to think who else but yeah
okay cute I like this all right this is
probably your favorite
um you reference RuPaul's Drag Race on
this album when I tell you it was
gobsmacked got snack okay
um who is your favorite queen of all
time and why oh my gosh oh my God that's
such a big question it's silky nutmeg oh
yes yes well it has to be why
um
I always loved them from their first
season
and I've loved seeing their journey I
love how honest and raw and open they've
been and then when they did the Barbie
girl it just changed my life
um but I just they're just my favorite
drag queen to watch and I also Joe
would second to that is I love Nina West
Nina West is so special and wonderful
and this their smile is incredible and
all the activism stuff they do I find so
beautiful and they're just such a lovely
gorgeous person they just radiate what
that show's about I love it I'm very
impressed with you I really should say
RuPaul though my mother yeah let's be
honest that is truly the number one